[Musique]
un mois de soleil et de chaleur à paris
les plages de rivière connaissent une
affluence considérable la seine la marne
et même l'oise watts à courir pour
planer et se rafraîchir et milliers de
jeunes parisiens et des parisiennes
[Musique]
las il faudra bientôt quitter le maillot
revêtir le costume de ville et terre
sous le soleil des kilomètres en vélo ou
en auto bus pour rentrer chez soi
dommage ou magnifique lac du bois de
boulogne
seuls les signes plus taxés d il est
vrai que les enfants sont plus favorisés
et une piscine miniature leur est
consacré cependant peut-on souhaiter que
la merveilleuse piscine du racing club
engage les pouvoirs publics à
l'aménagement au coeur même du poids
d'une place qui serait nous en sommes
persuadés d'en apprécier des parisiens
mais dès aujourd'hui paris doit être
fier de ses installations sportives
créer à sa porte mène dans un cadre
splendide et de bien des capitales
peuvent lui envier un mois de soleil et
de chaleur à paris les plages de rivière
connaissent une affluence considérable
la seine la marne puis même l'oise boîte
à courir pour flâner et se rafraîchir
des milliers de jeunes parisiens et des
parisiennes
non
on
hélas il faudra bientôt quitter le
maillot revêtir le costume de ville et
faire sous le soleil des kilomètres en
vélo ou en bus pour rentrer chez soi
dommage ou magnifique lac du bois de
boulogne
seuls les signes puissent accéder il est
vrai que les enfants sont plus favorisés
et une piscine miniature leur est
consacré cependant peut-on souhaiter que
la merveilleuse piscine du racing club
engage les pouvoirs publics à
l'aménagement au coeur même du bois
d'une place qui serait nous en sommes
persuadés d'en apprécier des parisiens
mènent dès aujourd'hui paris doit être
fier de ses installations sportives
créer à sa porte même dans un cadre
splendide et de bien des capitales
peuvent lui envier
[Musique]